[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ne paiera pas pendant des jours, je sais
[Musique]
le certains oh non le long meme vieux douloureux
ne paiera pas pendant des jours jolie âme
[Musique]
maman paie pour
toi
[Musique]
ça vivra ou oh mon
je parie que je t'ai volé j'ai fredonné un trou
mon père n'est jamais rentré disco Vasu Oh
ici à tuer le
sourire tourner - je me tourne pour essayer à la place tu
m'as arrêté tu m'as sauvé
[Musique]
le temps
laissé derrière nous alors que nous étions dans le désert le
temps et ton sourire ne reviendra pas du
désert  gagner toute la journée
blessé mon esprit est resté derrière car nous avons
traversé la journée
monsieur
[Musique]
oui Papa Veej Bali buku merde est ici sur
jared develli polyamide bénédictions frère
[Musique]
Marvel était-il cardé ils vont vraiment
aller se faufiler un jour d'arme à feu alors  quelque chose
n'a aucune valeur mais je vois notre talent sur un
forum public.
[Musique]
mon
tour de taille à la fin nous n'étions
que d'autres
[Musique
] sans temps à perdre
nous sommes pressés mais le monde n'attendra pas
nous sommes pressés alors nous restons éveillés
nous sommes pressés  monde une fois
attends
nous sommes pressés alors nous restons éveillés
Le talent de préparation à l'écart sur
ce n'a littéralement pas informé ma déclaration
Le ton thermique de la trace ninja de Sonya Martha
et cette table est de réduire l'unité sur un
cerveau plus de talent sur un dingaling sur l'
échelle
merci Sabatini Lisa Bell sifflet ouais nous avons
vu contrôler un accordéon sur Sheila
cyclamen  Ipanema Rajan Cassia Veeru
Aurora Christy TransAm  bascarsija
choqué via l'étranger la matraque une tasse il y a de la pâte molle
t-con board Edison se déplaçant sur la
chanson
[Musique] les
larmes nous brûlons aussi vite que vous pourriez
voler mon visage fondant pour le passé la
fièvre m'a sorti de ma poitrine
naviguant vers le vôtre où  Je pourrais me reposer au
moins nous pourrions respirer ensemble au moins
nous pourrions partir si seulement je pouvais
si seulement je pouvais au moins nous pourrions rêver
ensemble au moins nous dormirions si seulement
je pouvais les
doigts aussi noirs que la terre mes jambes dans
un nuage de codons à moins que  matin Farah au
moins nous pourrions pleurer ensemble au moins nous
pourrions sourire si seulement je pouvais
si seulement je pouvais au moins nous pourrions mourir
ensemble au moins nous essaierions si seulement je
pouvais
si seulement je pouvais au moins nous pourrions mourir
ensemble au moins nous le ferions  essayez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous